هل ينهر سد النهضه سؤال اصبح حديثا
الكثيرين مؤخرا بعدما ضرب اثيوبيا زلزال
بقوه اربع فاصله اربعه على مقياس ريختر
قبل يومين وتوقعات بوقوع زلازل اخرى
مستقبلا لكن لماذا هذا الزلزال تحديدا
خبراء اوضحوا ان الزلزال الاخير هو الاقرب
لموقع سد النهضه من زلازل تعرضت لها
اثيوبيا خلال المئه عام الماضيه فمركزه
يبعد عن السد نحو 100 كم فقط الا ان تاثير
المدمره لهذه الزلازل سيحدث في حال وصلت
قوه اي منها الى خمس درجات على مقياس
ريختر خصوصا مع وجود مخزون كبير من المياه
في السده واذا حدث ذلك ستغرق المناطق
المحيطه به اضافه الى اجزاء من السودان في
المقابل يرى مختصون ان السد الذي يعد
مقاوما للزلازل لن ينهار ولكن قد يتعرض
الى تخلخلات على اطرافه وحوله